tomorrow on bleacher report throughout
the entire bleacher report Empire you
can catch the 420 round table in which
Matt Barnes chats with Al Harrington
Kenyon Martin and Cuttino Mobley about
cannabis usage in the National
Basketball Association how are you how
about yourself how much does the NBA
want you to talk about this I'm not sure
I think Adam silver is very with it so
to speak and you know he obviously says
there's rules and regulations right now
but he's open for conversation down the
road so I think the fact that he's
willing to even listen is a big step
well what would the do you want no rules
and regulations about this um I think
obviously there's [ __ ] there's a big did
you always want to have rules and
regulations I just think that with more
education behind cannabis they'll
understand the benefits I think
everyone's stuck in the old stigma and
stereotypes of back in the day that it's
you know a gateway drug and it's bad for
this and it's bad for that but uh you
know what he did for me throughout my
career even throughout my college career
in high school career I'm glad that
there's medical research backing that up
now because I know what it did for me
personally what did it do for you first
it relaxed me it was something that able
allowed me to sleep easier and was
something that took pain away cuz I'm
not really big on alcohol or or
painkillers then it was something that
just put me in a different area where I
was able to relax and be at peace for a
small part of my day well I know and the
four NFL players that it would be
something for pain relief certainly
after a career but during the playing
career but we all know that even Howie
Long Pro Football Hall of Famers come on
this show and called every snap in the
NFL a car crash I mean how how physical
is the NBA to the point where you need
marijuana is pain man um the NBA's
physical from the standpoint of you know
we don't have pads on so that ground is
unforgiving that court is gonna win
every single time you hit it but then
from you know surgeries botched
surgeries ankle injuries broken fingers
you know things here and there that you
know a trainer would just throw any kind
of painkiller at you for which makes you
feel bad and like that pinkos only made
me really nauseous that's why I was
never really a fan of them and at the
same time that they're destroying the
insides so you know I just realized that
even though he's illegal you know I
found a way to be able to manage it
responsibly
use it and it was my substitution for
painkillers I've just I gotta ask the
question did you ever play a game hi
um I smoke before games it was never
right before what I would do is I'd go
to shoot around I'd come home after
shooting around smoke a joint take a nap
take a shower and then go to the game
and you were able to function yeah I did
in my whole career your whole career my
whole career
did you ever test I did I failed two
tests but I just kind of found out you
know trial and error I realize like I
said I wasn't doing it like I would do
in the summer time I was doing much more
responsibly and and as needed but I just
found out if I drank a lot of water and
ate clean that I was able to you know
get it out of my system in time mm-hmm
and it you don't and do you think you
would have been able to make it through
14 seasons in the NBA without not that
regimen
no not only from the pain standpoint but
just I mean my life has been
well-documented the crazy stuff on and
off the court and you should be able to
be able to focus you know what I mean
because we don't get a break you know
once that ball goes up not matter if I
went through a divorce and my mom died
or I got a fight with someone with the
world talking about it during those two
hours that there's no excuses and I
think it allowed me to focus in and in
handle my business what I need to know
I'm at a concert I oh I always say this
too or at a sporting event
I'll be honest I'd rather be behind
somebody smoking than somebody drink oh
yeah
without a doubt there's no question
because there's no there's usually no
fights when somebody is smoking rather
than drinking you anything you go crazy
that said though I mean the stuff that
you said documented it's been crazy in
your life could you attribute any of
that to its I can keep no I can
contribute to me being able to put the
fire out so to speak by smoking like I
said it was you know I was painted you
know and I earned some but just as the
bad guy you know what I mean which was
you know reputation has earned whether
good or bad so just to be able to kind
of block out all the negative that I
always got from life from the game in
general like I said it just allowed me
to focus and calm down and think clearly
Matt Barnes here on the Rich Eisen show
so when it comes down to it how much is
going cuz and your perfect person to ask
this I mean you won with the Golden
State Warriors last year how prevalent
is it in the NBA right now
um it's out there it's definitely out
there you know I really don't like to
speak on other people's situations I
speak on mine only but uh yeah it was
definitely something during the season
before after games practices it was
something I did regularly okay and how
close do you think it could be to come
in the NBA that you think it should be I
think it's it's obviously gonna be a
process I think CBD creams and oils will
probably make their way into the NBA and
professional sports shortly because you
know all the tests have been random
they've been cleared so I think that's
the next step and then continuing to
have an open conversation with obviously
uh mr. silver and you know commissioners
across other professional outlets I
think it's only a matter of time I'd say
two or three years probably how hard is
it to get popped under the current rules
Oh MBA it's you're most likely gonna get
popped you know I mean like I said I
played I was a veteran I was able to
understand what my body need and how
long it took to get out sure these four
random drug tests you know
hypothetically I can if I was in the
season right now I can get drug tested
tomorrow morning and not it would be
random so you wouldn't know now we had
maverick Carter on here at the outset of
the NBA season and he was on here
promoting uninterrupted having an Al
Harrington feature a analyst al has
maybe as his business I mean this is
this is his business
yeah see I was someone we play with him
going state and funny enough he was one
of the guys at the time that didn't
smoke one on that we believe team back
in the day and that team was a handful
so to speak but how was one of the guys
that didn't do it um you know what I
mean it al started smoking oddly enough
after he had two botched knee surgeries
and he had caught an infection in his
knee and the painkillers weren't working
so he started smoking and found instant
relief and that and then his his
grandmother which his company is called
biola she was taking a you know a whole
mess of pills and obviously her being
older she know she was on the old at it
that you know it's bad and you know all
the negative aspects but you know al got
her to try some CBD stuff and took her
pain away and you know that's just one
of several stories that I've heard where
people have you know opened their eyes
to it and educated themselves and become
fans of it so those who are going to be
seeking out the bleacher report for
twenty round table what what should they
expect to see um just open and real are
you hosting it
I'm an executive producer on the program
on the project but I'm not actually
hosting we have a host but I think we
sat down with NFL guys be a snoop oops
not involved I think I'm gonna get snoop
involved at some point cuz I mean that
he's hosting the Joker's while right now
him and his team help with some of the
merchandise stuff that's coming out
behind behind the whole situation but um
I just think open and real dialogue and
for people to understand that you know
it's something that could be beneficial
well you know used the right way I think
a lot of people fear because you know
you we're sending the wrong message to
children which I agree you know I have
kids myself so it's something that needs
to be educated needs to be discussed but
at the same time you know alcohol is out
there cigarettes are out there pills and
encoding lean are prevalent you know
among youth today and I know personally
that you know smoking a joint is a lot
better than doing any of those things I
just mentioned so with a few minutes I
have left with you Matt Barnes I do want
to talk some hoops do you think the
Warriors are in trouble this year I
don't I think that it's good stuffs
getting some rest hopefully he can come
back you know somewhat healthy I don't
think anyone at this point the season is
healthy but you got to remember them
they still got Kady
they still got clay we still got
draymond they got Shawn they got Andre I
mean it's just been a process and being
a part of that locker room last year I
understood what that process was you
know they know that they're playing til
June every single season so you know
what happens during the regular season
is kind of whatever you know you want to
continue to build your chemistry stay
healthy and get ready for this time of
the season right now on what they also
have though is a viable threat
I mean harden goes to know you're 18
last night and they still by 20 they
know the rocket just got I talked to
Chris Paul this morning I'm happy for
him you know Trevor Ariza is a good
friend of mine
yeah but whether the Rockets are scary
what you say what was your may I
eavesdrop on your yeah I'm just just
happy for Chris and I told him to stop
playing with those guys out there like
that stop toying with them boys but you
know just happy for Chris you know
someone longtime teammate with the
Clippers and I really just see him out
there smiling and happy and getting to
play off the ball a little bit and being
someone that can spot up and shoot an
attack on the catch and you know that's
something that he's always wanted to do
so I'm really happy and but Houston is a
scary team there's no clear-cut
anybody coming down the West because you
know although go and say
defending champs Houston looks amazing
okay if you were in charge of the
Clippers what move would you make I'd
get quite Leonard I would part ways with
Doc Rivers I would find a way to keep
the Andre Jordan and and go why would
you part ways with Doc I just think his
time is up there you know I think he
came in with our situation when we
probably had the best clipper team of
all time and it kind of crumbled in his
hands
nope not placing blame on him as a whole
I think we all may have played a part in
it but I just think you know sometimes
things have run their course I think
that situation is definitely ran its
course but it's a great situation I love
Steve Ballmer and what he's brought to
the organization the fan base is amazing
but yeah if you can go out there and get
someone that karateka wide to kind of
rebuild your franchise and be the
cornerstone be able to keep the Andre
Jordan they got some good young pieces
from trading Blake Griffin away so I
think they're one player in a new coach
away from getting back in the minute
where do you think LeBron is by the end
of July I would love to see him come to
the Lakers I'm still a I grew up a Laker
fan so I'd love to see him come to LA I
think it'd be amazing in Philly but you
know I would love to see him come to LA
in this career out here mentor this
young up-and-coming team which is full
of talent and team up with Matt adjust
on the business side Matt Barnes always
love having your on thanks for coming
here
thank you you got to check out again the
420 roundtable on bleacher report that
debuts Friday the 20th of April for 24
being here for 19 that's Matt Barnes the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience